hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing one of the
greatest chess matches that ever
happened it is the 1858 match between
paul charles murphy and adolf anderson
uh that took place in paris and this is
game five of the match so if you've been
following so far uh the first four games
anderson won the first one the second
one ended in a draw and morphe uh got
his first point of the match in game
three then morphe also won game four uh
and now morphe is leading the match by
one point margin and this is game five
so it features a really cool uh cool
opening uh it is the scandinavian
defense and uh anderson again goes all
out he just uh you know attacks morphe
with everything he has and uh compared
to uh to anderson morphy really is more
of a positional player and uh well one
might say that morphe is the the the
world's first positional player uh but
uh you you'll see what i mean by this so
uh morphe with the white pieces in game
five of this great match opens with e4
and we have d5 the scandinavian defense
by anderson morphy accepts the pawn and
now knight to f6 so not recollecting the
pawn uh and allowing morphy to start
harassing his queen but rather knight to
f6 and now more if he could defend his
pawn then we play c6 and then we
continue in the style of this uh sort of
a
gambit play but morphy not interested in
that he just plays d4 gives back the
pawn knight captures and now c4 attacks
this knight this is the martial
variation of the of the scandinavian
knight back to f6 and now knight to c3
we have bishop to f5 uh anderson
continues developing we have knight to
f3 e6 ending now bishop to e3 we have
bishop to b4 painting morphy's knight
here
and now comes queen to b3 you could also
go queen to a4 check kind of claim that
the bishop here is undefended but then
knight to c6 nicely defends the bishop
and blocks czech so it's not a problem
so queen the b3 by morphe attacking the
bishop and it is now as of move eight
that we have a completely new game as
this position has never been reached
again so let's see let's see what
happens here
uh anderson accepts uh this challenge he
grabs the knight with check b captures
on c3 and now morphe is still attacking
the b7 pawn and it would seem um a sort
of a characteristic for anderson to play
something like knight b to d7 give up
the pawn then castle and then just
continue as morphy's king is still in
the center of the board but it's almost
as if uh losing um the last two games to
morphy is making anderson more cautious
so he plays bishop to e4 now puts
pressure on the knight and the defends
his b7 pawn knights to d2 morphy attacks
now the bishop here and bishop back to
c6 and now bishop to d3 the bishops are
now developed characteristic of uh
morphe style he often places his bishop
son e3 and d3 and he's asking anderson
are you maybe interested in a pawn but
grabbing this pawn doesn't do all that
much the black king is still in the
center of the board you can play rook to
g1 then the bishop has to move then
you're gonna pick up the g7 pawn and if
anyone is attacking here it's definitely
white so instead after bishop to d3
knight beat to d7 by anderson and now
queen back to c2 uh anderson now sees
okay the queen and bishop are attacking
the h7 pawn so at some point i want a
castle i want to play h6
but now i
i actually could capture on g2 but i'm
not interested in this i don't want to
grab any pawns i'm the one who wants to
attack so h6 and now uh morphe castles
we have castles by anderson and now rook
a to e1 so
morphe's pieces are now fully developed
anderson has yet to finish his
development so here he plays b6 and one
might think that okay he just wants to
play bishop back to b7 maybe rook c8 and
c5 but he's actually planning queen to
c8 to b7 and then putting pressure along
this um
long diagonal so h3 by morphe taking
away the g4 square from black's pieces
and now queen to c8 preparing queen to
b7 uh but now king to h2 now morphy says
i don't care about this i'm just going
to play g4 put my rooks on the g file
and then hopefully advance it all the
way to g5 open up the g file and start
an attack on your king so anderson says
all right maybe this plan isn't as great
i'm just going to play king the h8 and
i'm gonna uh try in the double rooks on
the g file as well
so rook the g1 by morphe we have rook to
g8 by anderson g4 and now g5 and now
it's a really really crazy position both
of them are kind of opening up their
their king side completely and
understand figuring okay maybe my plan
with v6 queen here and here maybe isn't
so great as now all the action will be
happening on the king's side uh but um
yeah it's a very interesting position
and there is one thing that morphe can
do to really take advantage of the
queen's absence and well the queen side
works absence from the kings side so
feel free to pause the video and try and
figure out what you would play here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh finding any
interesting move but for those of you
who founded the correct continuation
then congratulations you are a true
master of positional play uh and the
move is now f4 you have to bust open the
position here you could also play rook e
to f1 and then execute f4 that is also
perfectly fine but f4 has to be
a part of your plan so here morphe
doesn't prepare it morphy just strikes
with f4 right away and now anderson
brings the queen back queen to f8 there
really is no active move you can play
here uh capturing here makes absolutely
no sense uh you're just gonna capture
and then continue with the g5 uh and
there's there are there are really no
moves that improve understand position
so he has to play a queen to a f8 it is
in fact the strongest move recommended
by the engine so anderson knows that
this is very much required and well the
queen will also be used for attacking
purposes if morphe allows it so rook the
g3 interestingly anderson has a
beautiful light square bishop here
controlling this entire diagonal but
morphe will use the dark squares and
he's going to double up rooks on g1 and
g3 that are dark squares and he doesn't
care about anderson's light square
bishop on c6 so rook to d8 uh and now
knight to f3 now putting even more
pressure on g5 and here anderson kind of
has to trade this bishop for night so
bishop captures on f3 rook captures on
f3 and now queen to d6 spinning the pawn
as the king is now on h2 but now morphy
says you don't you no longer have your
light square bishop so i'm going to
shift the king over on a light square so
knights the h5 now putting more pressure
on f4 and trying to give up the piece
this way but capturing right away
doesn't really
do all that much if you capture right
away then we're going to capture here
with check we're going to win back the
piece and uh well black black will have
very very decent attacking chances here
so instead after knight h5 morphe just
grabs the pawn on g5 with h captures on
g5 and now
morphy accepts the challenge now he
plays g captures on h5 and he allows
anderson to have this well sort of an
attack g4
now you have to capture this there's no
reason to to allow this uh
you know any for example g captures an
h3 with a discovery it's going to be
very unpleasant so here we have h
capture sanji 4 by morphe rook captures
on g4 and now king to f1 and now we have
f5 and here uh morphe is up a piece but
anderson has um
uh well he he does have compensation if
morphe allows him uh a move or two if he
plays uh you know not not the not the
best if you if he allows him to double
up on the g file for example maybe bring
the knight into the game and somehow
activate the queen then black's position
should be very good but morphy of course
not interested in that he plays queen to
f2 and he asks anderson what what is
your next move and there really aren't
all that many active moves anderson
finds seemingly the most active one and
that is knight to e5 attacking the rook
and the bishop here and of course if uh
you capture the knight you lose the
bishop with check but morphy says not a
problem my light square bishop isn't
doing really anything here you've
blocked it so i i really want to be left
with my dark square bishop so here at
morphe captures we have queen captures
on d3 uh delivering a check to the white
king queen to e2 blocking check and of
course queen e4 anderson in no position
to trade queens he has to play for the
attack uh and now uh well uh morphy
still has to be careful here if he plays
the still move like rook to f1 queen to
h1 is checkmate so you have to be
careful so here we have bishop to f2
morpheu offers a queen trade and
anderson of course declines queen back
to c6 we have looked at d1 uh morphe now
trying to trade off as many pieces as
possible rook captures we have queen
captures and now uh anderson really
wants to keep his queen here so morphy
can't move his rook you know queen to h1
would be would be very nice but also he
would very much enjoy grabbing some
pawns now because if he's not going to
have the attack he has to reclaim some
material so queen captures on c4 queen
to d3 morphe now offers a queen trait
and now even queen captures on a2 and
now much like in some previous games
anderson always sacrifices and he always
gains some sort of a compensation
because now he does have the past a
phone if he can push that pawn it could
be very unpleasant for morphe and morphe
has to find the most precise way to play
this and he does he plays a rook to g3
now it's uh very dangerous if you move
the rook then ideas like queen here
queen here come to mind so not really an
option so here we have queen to c4 by
anderson uh now of course you can't
capture the rook because you lose the
queen so morphy has to trade queens we
have captures captures and now rook to
g6 going after the backwards e6 pawn and
that's the absolute best way to play
this uh because it's not that simple
morphy yes has uh has a piece but it's a
bishop so you always have to be careful
when you're left with a bishop if those
pawns on the queen side start marching
uh could be very unpleasant so here rook
to c6 defending the backwards e6 pawn
and now c4 again morphe uh very very
precise uh it's uh it's a very tricky
move because this rook can't move
anywhere the bishop guards this the pawn
guards this this pawn guards this so
this rook is basically trapped if you
want to uh you know free this rook you
have to capture and allow morphe to
capture the e6 pawn so we have a5
anderson starts pushing his pawn but now
king e2 morphy says nope not a problem i
am well within the square of the pawn if
you play here i'm going to play here and
you can see that the white king is
safely in the square of the pawn so that
pawn will not be an issue uh so
understand basically without a move the
king has no active moves you have to
capture on c4 there's no other way to
play it like i said you could play this
but then king d3 we're going to play a3
now even bishop to e3 you don't even
have to you know worry about the king
the rook is very happily joining the
defense with a move like rook to g1 so
not much to do here and now this rook is
really stuck here because he can't even
capture the c4 pawn so instead after
king to e2 we have rook captures on c4
that's not a c4 rook captures on c4 uh
we have rook captures on e6 and now
comes rook to c2 with check forcing the
king back to keep an eye on the bishop
so king of three and now anderson
continues with his plan a4 he only needs
three more moves and that's it he
basically wins the game but that's uh
three moves that morphe will not allow
so rook to g6 and now uh we okay you
could continue with a3 but white always
has rook to g1 and you're guarding a1 so
really it's it's not a problem so rook
to c4 first if morphe starts advancing
his past pawn anderson wants to have
rook to e4 ready uh so here we have rook
to g1 and now a3 we have e6 by morphe a2
by anderson and now rook to a1 morphe
now has to block the pass pawn or rather
he doesn't but he he just wants to pick
it up he
figures that it's it's worth giving up
the e6 pawn for so rook to e4 morphy
grabs on a2 and anderson captures on e6
but now king to f4 now morphy will claim
this pawn anderson will claim sorry
morphe will claim this pawn as well uh
rook to d6 we have king captures on f5
and now rook to d5 with check king to g4
uh and now b5 now if you could somehow
start pushing these pawns and put the
rook behind the pass pawns then maybe
you you'd still have a way of playing
this uh but that's that's a lot of moves
rook a8 by morphe king a7 now rook to a7
going after the pawn here
uh anderson defends it would rook to d7
but it's a very passive way of defending
and now uh morphy plays bishop to g3 and
this is enough to win the game because
you have to realize one thing morphe
only has one pawn and he has a bishop so
if it's the wrong bishop uh you do not
want to be trading rooks but here we can
check it's the correct bishop and we are
well we are more than happy to trade
rooks uh if we had a light square bishop
the h8 the queening square uh will uh is
a dark square so having a light square
bishop would allow anderson to draw this
by making sure we have a dark square
bishop and that we're able to cover the
queening square we can trade rooks so
here uh rook the g7 check king h4 not
much for anderson to do here rook to f7
and now rook captures and c7 morphe of
course uh wants the trade here and he
was in this position on move 54 that
adolf anderson resigned in the game and
now morphe by winning game five takes a
two point lead uh in this epic match
that will surely continue very very soon
uh so yeah like i said uh there's
nothing for you to do here you have to
trade because uh well the the king is on
h7 so the rook can't go anywhere you
would have to trade here and now it's a
completely winning position uh like we
said because uh we uh our bishop can
cover the queening square and also
covers the b2 square so the black pawn
will not be able to cross we're just
gonna play bishop to e5 b3 now start
bringing our king into the game and
black has no most king g8 we're going to
play king g6 king f8 we're going to push
the pawn here put the pawn with check
the h8 square not available to the black
king we're going to queen the pawn and
that's it easily win the game so after
rook captures on c7 anderson resigned
and morphy is now leading the match by a
two-point margin so morphy really took
this approach in pretty much all of his
matches so first he loses then he maybe
gets a draw and then he just starts
playing really really well uh but it
seems that uh here anderson
uh kind of didn't uh you know fully
continue in his own style when i
mentioned in the beginning of the
game when he didn't allow morphe to grab
on b7 he could have just developed
knight b to d7 and allowed that capture
on b7 but he didn't uh and it seems like
you know uh anderson is starting to
fully realize how strong morphy is and
it's also maybe starting to get in his
head a little bit
but plenty of more games in this match
we'll see who reaches seven victories
first so stay tuned the morphe saga
continues promptly uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank david kimura henry wilson
marshall farrier julian sean and francis
ayer for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends uh so thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day